Daisy Ridley reveals whether Prince
Harry or Prince William would make a
better stormtrooper such an amazing job
in the film et spoke with the actress at
the premiere of her new film Star Wars
the last Jedi on Saturday where she
played coy on Prince Harry and Prince
William's involvement in the film I
cannot comment on whether the princess
costume Gymkhana though the 25 year old
actress did admit which brother she
thinks would make the best stormtrooper
by the way it's so exciting they're
coming to the European premiere how
excited are you already so I'm like yeah
yeah just to catch up how you've been
you got engaged nice now it's that great
maybe Megan more Colin I don't delicious
you never know maybe it's a surprise
babies and surprise and then no one will
care about them and opened up about the
craziest thing a fan has ever asked her
to do probably the signing like t-shirts
and stuff with it on their bodies it's
weird funny I don't take my heart in
that please stop us
that's probably the way of it the most
about people are pretty normal but it's
just like sign my belly like no I'm
going thank you
[Music]
you